hello everyone how's everybody doing
hope you're doing fine I have a little
interesting geo geometry class today but
I'd like to start with questions had
questions about extinction and about
another subject which is at the root of
physics which is what is an object okay
so let's start with these comments here
first one now has to do with extinction
and a fella says there are lost tribes
that have had little to no contact with
humanity
they don't live in cities and are not
subject to economic collapse and the
starvation let's grant your theory of
economic collapse and worldwide
starvation these humans will survive
because they are not affected by your
mechanism of extinction as they are
isolated not in cities have lived as
hunter-gatherers or agricultural
existence does humanity survives and
eventually 100 and 1000 years later will
repopulate the earth
[Laughter]
I mentioned this comment because lots of
people have over the years mentioned
this thing you know so they say you know
what about those Lost Tribes and okay so
let's go on with my answer here
you know I synthesized them okay first
of all the tribes are not lost there are
no such thing as Lost Tribes you know
the satellites have located everything
on earth you can see a matchbox from the
satellites okay
so every bit of land on earth has been
already scouted so to speak and then
some tribes you know they're just made
of most of these so-called lost tribes
are really known as uncontacted tribes
that we know they're there but we just
haven't contacted them or they refuse
contact or whatever we don't want to
bother them that sort of thing okay some
of our just composes a few families
in one cases I'm gonna show in a minute
there's only four families forming the
so-called tribe and most of them in fact
none of them are above a thousand in
population and most of those populations
have already had contact will caught
with a white man with a civilized man
right and people who are truly living in
the jungles all on their own not
troubled by us very very few on the
planet okay and that's why because of
that third point because we cover their
defense budget we protect them you know
it's a they they they are not bothered
even by tourists because we don't let
the tourists go over there otherwise
lots of people would go in there in that
area especially loggers who want to get
rid of some of these Indians or whatever
you want to call it natives and they you
know these natives are in the way
they're in the way of progress right and
then there's the issue of loss of
genetic diversity which I'll talk at the
end but let's let's look at some of
these things here's a group of people
that a few tribes that I looked up this
reference at this photo person gave me I
pulled these out of there okay just to
give you an idea what we mean by these
uncontacted tribes who are these people
you know and here's a couple of them one
is the IRA oh there's supposedly five
thousand six hundred most um right are
already in civilization of these five
thousand six hundred when you look him
up but says traditionally nomadic
hunter-gatherers right that's tradition
right the majority of the population was
said and terrorized by missionaries in
the 20th century okay and so a lot of
these people they're no longer
uncontacted and for sure problem most of
them don't live in the jungles the few
remaining uncontacted ir Yuriko are
threatened by deforestation and loss of
territory again we have to give them
because otherwise between tourists and
loggers and who knows who wants their
land you know they'll take over so the
government said lotty these are natives
we want to we want a free determination
of these people so we don't want anyone
bothering them so we so the government
protects them okay
yep the you can believe you composed of
four families oh man big tribe they have
intermittent contact with the
Christianize Yuki okay so so there's a
there's the uncontacted and the
contacted and most of them are contacted
and they they're Christians probably
missionaries went there civilize them
you know give them guns that kind of
thing sex you know XXX movies there the
other one hi meri ma marry mom okay
their area has recently been declared
protected you need protection okay
otherwise you know someone's gonna go in
there and what they can't even kill them
for all we know you know and so you
gotta keep that in mind and then you
have the ymp in the french guiana and
there's another guy on out there that
has the same situations this one
practice slash-and-burn agriculture i've
if they're practicing agriculture that
means they're not hunter-gatherers that
means they're not in the forests in the
jungles okay we're talking about
something else when we're talking about
agriculture we're talking about a much
more advanced man than the basal
hunter-gatherer you know talking about
maybe upper upper Palaeolithic forty
fifty thousand years ago you know we're
talking about something else here we're
talking about people who have
agriculture okay and they subsist a
month on you know all those things of
sweet potatoes yams mañana's okay those
they grow okay and says the my RiRi
community carries out limited
exploitation of gold claims uh-huh now
that's hunter-gathering I guess trade
and hunter-gathering the way up is that
work as civil
in the local administration are paid
true gifts okay so a lot of these are
put in there for padding in in the
article like him oh we have all these
tribes that have not been contacted now
they're they're put in there for for
paddy ninety percent of them there's
very very few people who have no contact
and those people are protected because
someone's gonna kill them and it turns
out that you know if the world collapses
okay and goes to hell the whole global
economy first thing and anyone near
there is gonna do is gonna go in there
kill and cannibalize them or whatever
and then and if they don't do that
they're gonna hunt whatever these people
hunted and so these people will be
marginalized from their source of food
anyways so to think that these
hunter-gatherers are going to survive
the collapse of global economy because
they're not in touch with us it just
shows that these people are not thinking
they they don't have their thinking caps
on okay here's a one group of people
that became famous recently and their
North is known as the North Sentinel
island they and it's there in the middle
of nowhere
okay and it's a Nylund belongs to India
these people are protected it turns out
that you know missionary went there I
think he was a young guy about 26 years
old and these guys killed them and
that's why they were in the news and you
know there's a lot of fishermen those
regions they want to go to this island
to fish and so on and the government
won't let them in other words these
tribes are protected okay and you know
these these are one of the things you
got to keep in mind you know the first
people who are gonna go in the states
are going to be the Amish why because
they're not protected right now we're
paying for their protection okay and
they're protected by the courts and
they're protected by you know
military-style you know police etc
tomorrow let's go on there's no
protection and if these guys don't even
have a radio to know what's going on out
there they're gonna be swamped by all
kinds of people who are starving they're
just gonna overrun they're far
eat them as well so this notion that the
uncontacted or people who can grow their
own stuff and do not participate in the
world economy you're gonna survive those
are the first people who are gonna go
it's the other way around okay we're
gonna slaughter them first for sure
because they have no protection at that
point okay
this is I went to Brazil you can see
with my family some time ago and I went
to see the takuna and on the right
you'll see an old picture of the
takuya's on the left you'll see you know
my party over there and you can see some
of the ladies you know they have no bras
they're there in their natural state and
it turns out that when we've been on the
boat when I'm in this little boat that
we went there I think it was like half
an hour to one hour ride something like
that and the Indians over there the
natives they got a word that tourists
were coming and so the girls took off
their blouses and their bras that's what
they did before we came painted their
face is that kind of thing you know they
put on the show and you can tell because
you don't have these huts which have
standing above the level of water with
poles because water rises every now and
dance the river rises the Amazon River
and so they have these Hut's up there
but what you'll see is an antenna come
out of their houses they all have TV in
there you know and the girls guys a girl
you know they go to the city and during
the day they go to school you know I
have to travel in any way they can
usually by boat to the cities to get an
education some of the girls you know
they're prostitutes they work the night
shift and so to think that and and these
people these two Cunha they're in touch
with those uncontacted tribes and those
are you know these people are smarter
than those and that they'll for sure
liquidate anyone who's out there who's
unknown uncontacted so this notion that
you know these people will survive is
it's just incredible and here's proof
you're proof will give you
okay here we have four different types
of of societies okay and what you see
here is on the upper left these are bad
ones okay and they go around with your
camels and so on you can see there
they've got dresses that they probably
wouldn't manufacture out there in the
middle of the desert
now they trade they trade and therefore
they're in contact even though they're
nomads and they don't really participate
in general with the global economy they
they do trade and they're in contact
with our economy so they do depend in
many ways on us and by us I mean the
civilized world you know these are
considered people who are not so
civilized even though they are quite
civilized I think it's just their way of
life on the bottom right you'll see the
same thing in Afghanistan you'll see
their dresses you know where they get
those dresses they get them up there in
the mountains on the upper right you'll
see the pygmies and you can see the kids
are wearing shirts and I think they
don't make them in that Hut behind them
I think that you'd make those shirts
somewhere else
okay so even the pygmies are in contact
with civilization and then on the bottom
left you see what I'm talking about
these are from New Guinea Papua New
Guinea and you know they they they have
scores to settle with rival tribes and
what these people do is they trade with
the white man with the civilized man
right they trade their bows and arrows
or whatever they trade I don't know for
guns because they have scores to settle
with tribes and there are tribes within
New Guinea which are uncontacted but
these people know where they are and
they're gonna hunt them down again you
know this notion that someone will
survive out there because he's not in
contact with our civilization or with
with our economics is absolute none that
means these people again are not
thinking and here's a more proof you are
proof here's the famous case of Maori is
in New Zealand that wiped out or molten
more or less almost wiped out the more
you
Cory says the invaders this this an
article in the Wikipedia but I had for a
long time says the invaders my worry
right kill the 12 year old girl and hung
her flesh on posts talk about civilized
people right there but there was
civilization they proceeded to enslave
some more Yuri and kill and cannibalize
others with the arrival of a second
group parties of warriors armed with
muskets clubs and tomahawks led by their
Chiefs walk through the more URI tribal
territories and settlements without
warning permission or greeting if the
district if the districts were wanted by
the invaders they curtly informed the
inhabitants that their land had been
taken and the more Yuri living there
were now their vassals okay and a more
hairy survivor recalled the Maori
commenced to kill us like sheep only 101
more Yuri out of a population about
2,000 were left alive by 1862 so you
want to know what happens to long-lost
tribes first they're not long lost we
found them all second their uncontacted
meaning that we're protecting them
that's why they're not uncontacted we
know where they are and third you know
when that protection is gone they're
gonna be the first ones to be gone okay
so now this notion that you know
someone's gonna survive because they're
not in contact with our economic system
is absolutely nonsense okay here's
another one I think from the same fellow
and he says says a more likely scenario
inspired by the French Revolution this
scenario we are again at the precipice
of economic collapse okay he goes
through these steps he says large
companies start producing food economic
collapse people revolt government either
overthrown is either overthrown or
decides to act in people's favor and
takes over the big corporations assets
government starts producing food for the
people and people survive what's wrong
with all this well the what's wrong with
this is again you know people mistake
the manufacturing
and agricultural age of the French
Revolution even you can take that as far
as the Russian Revolution of 1917 you
know that's definitely what we have
today we have a new world today just in
case you have noticed there are no
countries today okay there are no
countries today we have what is called
globalization that means the
corporations are multinationals ok and
so now we have a global economy or we're
working towards that we haven't
perfected it yet but that's where the
artificial man's artificial economy is
going towards we're making a one-world
government so to speak in terms of
economics ok so when it collapses you
know in all these cases there was always
some country was doing good or none
other ones doing bad and ones that were
doing bad the politicians managed to get
resources from another place to fill the
fill the hole so to speak but when the
global economy collapses you know the
Martians are not going to help come here
and help us ok they look too far away ok
so so no it's a totally different
situation with with a collapse happening
today by the way when I say collapse I
mean money will be no more see these
people still have money and so that's
not the same situation either from that
point of view ok so there's many things
wrong yeah this guy mentioned is that
you know I made false predictions you
know I said some time ago that we would
be gone extinction of man maybe in a few
years months or years and yeah you have
to distinguish the theory from the
prediction prediction is religion that's
my religion you know I have my beliefs
and I'm a lousy astrologer I've admitted
that many times you know you don't have
to look at my predictions that's my
sense of what's going on but that has
nothing to do with the mechanism that
I'm explaining what I'm talking you know
it's it's raising a straw man by saying
all Bill's prediction failed so his
theory is wrong no the theory has
nothing to do with a prediction ok
there's a two different
you wanna tag you you attack the the
mechanism because that's what's the part
of science the other ones part of
religion my personal beliefs you know to
raise the issue say hey Bill your
prediction came out wrong no I lost that
the horses too you know by the way you
know III bet on that horse I knew it was
gonna win but he didn't win it so does
that mean my theory is incorrect
I mean with this one thing you have to
do with the other so so yeah we got
problems with a lot of that stuff
anyways here's the second another
comment and this one brings up the issue
of Shape he says shape is not form this
is a second or third individual that
mentions this so I want to clarify this
because the word object is crucial in
physics so I'm gonna fight that to the
end of the earth
okay we need to defend the definition of
object no matter what and so shape is
not form we observe shape in space not
form that which has form is is an object
okay and Matthews a shape not form okay
so what are my replies to that I've got
a little synthesis here hope I get the
right one ordinary speech that's what
he's talking about
okay you know in the speech we say shape
and form are two different things and
you can say in ordinary speech shape
refers to 2d whereas form refers to 3d
objects out there in space in physics
shape and form are synonyms we can't
make a distinction because we have to we
we only have on and off yes or no black
or white you know it's got to be just
two offices there's no there's no maybe
there's no gray okay so you have to
define the word object and and we
defined it as that which has shape you
want to use the word form same thing
that was a shape or form it doesn't
matter it has to have some kind of
outline some kind of perimeter some
surface if applicable okay but it has to
have just an outline that's it
if there is an outline it has shape or
form whatever you want to call it it
doesn't matter and then it is an object
by definition otherwise you know the
person who wants to go through all this
stuff you know gets into this these
little rabbit holes you know is a cube
you know perfect ideal cube it does that
have shape or form because we can only
see an ideal cube on a 2d surface okay
and so the question is you know or we
say that's got shape or we now say it's
got form because it's 3d and we get all
these rabbit holes we're trying to find
out you know what the definition of the
word object is and these people say
where we have all kinds of objects we
have 2d objects and we have 3d objects
and maybe you even have 4d objects like
you know
Tesla racks or spacetimes or whatever we
can't get into all that nonsense because
first of all in physics we do not have
adjectives next to a noun an object we
don't there is no such thing as a black
cat in physics there's only a thing as a
cat okay there's no black cat no white
cat no yellow cat okay and to say well
this is a shape object and this is in a
a form object no such thing there's only
an object you got to define the word
object and so the issue here is the
proponent of shape not equal form must
define object unambiguously and
rationally to be used consistently
scientifically right in physics that's
that's the homework right so you can't
just come in here and say well you know
I don't like the word form or the word
shape to be used as a definition of
object and just you find the word object
and we'll know we'll know what to use
and it's got to be used consistently and
you can't go through all these little
rabbit holes and say well these are
these kinds of objects because then you
get into what the mathematicians have
they have mathematical objects and we'll
get to that a little bit today maybe
okay here's another comment last one
okay and it's got to do with the subject
matter of today it's got to do with
location seems to me a point is just a
location relative to the
it's associated with or helping to
define it doesn't matter what the point
actually looks like uh-huh I thought we
were doing geometry I mean does it
matter what a square looks like does it
matter what the cube looks like or a
sphere a pyramid you know these
so-called objects that are used in
geometry it doesn't matter what they
look like I can I can get a kid that
looks like a sphere doesn't matter what
it looks like hopefully it does because
if it's got to do with geometry it
better start looking like that shape
that's what geometry is first and
foremost about shape so it does matter
but then here's here Z the issues again
outlined okay put them over here not so
that you can see my face but so that I
can see them okay why use the word point
I mean if it's a location as you say
that's very simple when to use the word
location that was the issue and we're
not to say yeah location Y represented
pictorially to begin with with a dot why
do you put a dot there if you're gonna
say well it's a location dude you know
do we use constitute we use objects to
represent concepts are we using
shamanism is that what what physics is
about what geometry is about we're gonna
represent anger with Leopard how's that
for shamanism or we're gonna replay that
we're gonna say that the heart
represents love does that make sense in
physics or is that poetry and so this is
the issue whether why did they put a dot
if they're gonna say location when in a
caught point just use the word location
say hey you know this line has so many
locations and between any two locations
we can find infinite number of locations
you can say all that why use the word
point why use a representative with a
dot and confuse everybody and say well
you know you can put a billion dots
between two dots well I don't think so
depends on the dot size if if if you
have two dots and each one is one
centimeter wide or diameter right you
can't fit a gazillion and enter just
1017 there's a part you cannot fit a
gazillion dots of the for that size
between those two dots so no you cannot
make that statement once you put you
talk about objects you can only make
that statement if you're talking about
locations but then we use the word point
and confuse everybody and you know say
this is a thought but this is what it
means or this is what I'm gonna use okay
does the dot move I mean does a location
move you know I mean we can move the dot
can you move a location okay order is an
ordered pair of not any we have x and y
right or is that how to get to the
treasure chest
you know the pirate walks ten feet to
the right and I don't know 20 feet north
and he finds the treasure chest is that
10 20 is that a dot or are those the
instructions on how to find the treasure
chest we got all these problems where
with all of what the mathematicians have
created here because they're all
contradict one thing contradicts the
other okay it's an ordered pair time
interval is it a location or motion I
mean you know what is X Y X Y our
instructions on how to get to the
treasure chest right and you know they
have this notion called position in
mathematics and geometry and what are we
talking about we're talking about this
guy moving ten feet to the right 20
North right and we say so we're talking
about motion we're talking we're talking
about how to get there we're not talking
about location or position for that
matter we're talking about motion we're
saying this which you got to work you
will have to work walked 30 steps to
reach the treasure chest that's what
you're saying yeah and then ultimately
if its location what does it have to do
with geometry
you know geometry is a study of
first and foremost I mean you know of
course you're gonna do relations etc
bangles but then what this location have
to do with geometry the dot yeah that's
a figure yeah if you have a circle or
you have a square and you represent that
the dot you know that that that is your
representation of what you call point
well that's a 2d figure so that's a
figure that belongs to geometry but it's
too deep just what I'm staring at
objectively in front of me is 2d that's
why it's 2d and you say well you're not
supposed to look at the picture oh okay
what am I supposed to look at well you
guess you're supposed to imagine close
your eyes and imagine what it represents
Oh what does it represent it represent
location well why did you say that to
begin why don't you just say location
what is this nonsense about point okay
no wonder they can't define it after
what two thousand years two thousand
five hundred years since the Greeks
nobody can define the word point because
they have these different concepts
merged into this notion of point that's
why they can't define it and they never
will of course okay so let's go back to
where we were the other day we started
off with mr. Euclid and Euclid said the
following he said in his book right a
point is that which has no part whatever
that means right and he continues in
definition three says the ends of lines
are points okay so what is the issue the
first issue is that Euclid was like a
Harvard Graduate today you know he's got
a worthless degree because all he's done
is just memorize stuff created by others
okay I mean you name a reason people go
to Harvard or Cambridge that is to give
jobs to get contacts the right context
that's why they go there they don't go
there though to create new knowledge new
new theories or anything like that
because they're all mommy's boys they're
there people who someone paid their
tuition and their schooling they go
there they have money or they have
references or whatever and they go there
did to have good contacts to make
contacts right for their future careers
that's got nothing to do with science
that's got to do with politics and
religion and Euclid was you know a
Harvard graduate he was a cambric
graduate he was just a guy who was rich
who studied and what did you study he
studied what everybody else had already
created so he's just a student in this
sense and we remember him and glorify
him only because he's the guy who wrote
the book on geometry right but every
concept in there you know came from
before him he was in the third century
BC and you got people like Aristotle who
was in the fourth you got people like
Pythagoras he was in the sixth so you
know a lot of people preceded him by
decades and by centuries and they had
already but I mean you know the the
pyramids in Egypt they were built 3,000
years before Christ and so that guy must
have known a little bit about geometry
and a little bit about mathematics to
build that thing okay a little bit and
so you know a lot of these concepts have
been around for a long time and all did
you CLE did was kind of put them
together and one of the guys he
certainly got this from is this man you
know Aristotle Aristotle he's uh he
wrote several books or at least uh he's
credited with writing these books that's
not completely settled but it seems that
that's the case okay but Aristotle says
in his book in his book called physics
yeah book sex here the extremities of
two points can neither be one okay and
what is he referring to he says look if
you have a dot that's made like I like
to state it made of a single piece okay
if it's made of a single piece that
means it doesn't it's not made of parts
okay so that's that's my notion of what
of what single single piece is my notion
of continuity okay that's what he's
addressing here he's addressing
continuity and he says the extremities
of two points can either be one right
because if you got two you know you
can't make them into one that's what
he'd say
and second he's saying those thoughts
suppose he have no extremities I put him
in green there just to point out what
he's kind of referring to he's saying
they have no extremities because they're
made of a single piece and he calls that
indivisible okay and where does he get
this from he gets this from Democritus
and Lucifer's who was Democritus teacher
apparently okay that's not so either
because these guys we have no writings
from these people
we only know them through the writings
of people like Aristotle and what did
they invent well they invented the atom
or this is what they vote for whether
they were the creators of this also we
don't know but Democritus talked about
individuals and that's what the atom is
and that's what the point is okay that
which has no part well you'll see it at
the bottom that comes from Aristotle or
at least that's one of the sources you
could certainly use and he says the
extremities the ones can neither be one
nor together
why because since that which has no
parts this is Aristotle right can have
no extremity okay and the extremity in
the thing of which it is the extremity
being distinct yeah so no it was what
we're talking about here we're saying
that if those dots those two dots at the
top are made of each one is made of a
single piece Aristotle says you cannot
make something continuous with them you
get out make them because they have no
ends they have no extremity hey it's
made of a single piece and so this is my
term by the way okay so indivisible for
me just means made of a single piece I'd
like to use that because it's more
related to physics okay and so here you
have a single piece line box whatever
you want to call it at the bottom okay
and it's got no extremities because
there is no point at that extremity the
only way you can get it the the points
there is if you divide the box up chop
it up into pieces but then Aristotle is
saying that the
it's of that also have to be subdivided
of both they have to be divisible hey
and what is he referring to he is
referring to again he's trying to
address democritus's atom is indivisible
so you know they're classy and their
philosophy and their notion of what they
mean by continuity and what they mean by
discreteness because that's the fight
here the fight is between discrete and
continuous that's what it is whether
something which is continues can be made
of a single piece or it is segmented and
he's got the opposite notion of what I
have exactly is the opposite because my
notion is that an object is continuous
if it's made of a single piece and if
it's chopped up its segmented or or made
of discrete parts and Aristotle's notion
is that only if it's made of discrete
parts which themselves are chopped up
into segments only can then something be
continuous well why do you say this well
he's addressing two other issues he's
addressing motion and he's addressing
time neither which really has anything
to do with geometry but this is what the
Greeks did they mixed all these concepts
completely you know they bundled them up
into a single notion of line and point
every time you talk about the point he
talked about the line because there got
to be talking about continuity and why
are they talking about that because
we're gonna be talking about distance
they're not talking a length which even
today they they considered distance in
length synonyms
why because you measure both of them so
it doesn't matter if you're measuring a
table or the distance between two tables
it doesn't matter to a mathematician
because he's just looking at his
measuring tape and error I was also
talking about motion you know which is
more or less distance traveled in that
sense it's the same thing as distance
and they're talking about time and the
question is whether all these things are
these concepts are chopped up into
segments
into little pieces into little thoughts
into little locations points whatever
you want to call them or it's made of a
single piece may meeting continues
according to me you know okay let's
continue
so here's Erin and he comes up with this
other notion or this is really a summary
really geometry you know part point okay
that's that's at least Airy there
Aristotle's notion and I'm sure you
could got it from him just at least a
great degree he studied what Aristotle
wrote indivisible gets that from
Lucifer's and Democritus there Adam Adam
means indivisible that's why you know we
have that word today indivisible the
atom right which turns out was divisible
and the concept of continues that's
that's where they're gonna be applying
the word point which means so many
things location number ordered pair
means so many things and we have to be
careful because he keep switching from
one context to another but the notion of
continuous has to do with both the
notion of motion and the notion of time
okay then this so this is when they
arise with the geometric notion of lying
what is a line a line is geometry or are
we talking are we gotta talk about
motion displacement distance time what
are we talking about here and and this
is the issue they're gonna be confusing
all these in a bundle and so he says
these are words directly from his book
that which is continuous is composed of
points nothing that is continuous can be
composed of indivisible okay that means
he's suggesting that the point has to be
divisible if it wants to form something
continues such as a line okay that's an
important point that he's trying to make
and the last man a line cannot be
composed of points I'm sure a lot of
mathematicians wouldn't like that to
read that today the line being
continuous and the point indivisible so
he's saying the point
to be indivisible so how did they arrive
then at this no part point they're
saying that the point is made of no
parts so so we have two schools of
thought here kind of on the one hand we
have the point which should be divisible
according to Aristotle if it wants to
form part of a continuous line because
he's saying that one comes right after
another so he's talking about succession
of points and that's his notion of
continued continuity and the other guy
who says the point is the ultimate thing
the individual it is not made of parts
so that's what they're referring to when
they say it's not made of parts they're
not really saying zero-dimensional as
the notion has you know been because you
know bequeath or how we inherited it
today okay we inherited notion that you
know you have planes they're two
dimensional the line is one dimension
what's the point well it's zero
dimension that's not what Euclid or the
Greece in general we're referring to
when they're saying the point has no
part meaning meaning you know it's it's
not made of parts okay that's what and
these were the two schools of thought
when guy said it's it's not made of
parts because you have to have something
that makes up everything else and the
other guy says well we got a problem
because we're gonna explain time and
we're gonna explain motion we need to
have all these chopped up into locations
now we introduced location and and a
location can be chopped up into pieces
as well two more parts right and so if
we're gonna use the point the geometric
point to represent a location the print
had better be chopped to be able to be
chopped up into pieces as well so they
had these these philosophical you know
notions that they were discussing
debating and disagreeing on okay okay so
this is the issue the issue is that mr.
Aristotle is gonna extrapolate these
things to things that have nothing to do
with geometry even though he's talking
about physics there as you can see in
his book
he's talking about all kinds of stuff
that he mixes in there he says nor can a
point be in succession to a point or a
moment to a moment in such a way that
length can be composed of points now if
you talk about mixing Eric and syllable
notions he's talking about locations
being mixed with seconds moment a moment
right length which I guess it's meters
or centimeters or millimeters I don't
know what he was using but we got a
whole bunch of notions here put into
this word point yeah you know so he says
how can a point bein succession to a
point meaning I guess he's referring
near to the geometric point the dot next
to a dot that's what you're supposed to
visualize but then he immediately
changes to moment to moment which you
can imagine a second following second
and then the other guy lengths maybe a
centimeter following a centimeter you
know what do we doing what is he doing
here what is he trying to do with all
these this mixture and he continues that
which is intermediate between points is
always aligned so we so we have you know
a line separates two points is he
referring to a line now he's referring
to distance but he calls that a line or
designates it as a line or represents it
with the geometric line that's how we
get where our one dimensional line now
you know the distance between two points
is a straight line right that's the
definition of line today you know
shortest distance between two points so
we're talking we're saying that a line
is a distance okay and that which
intermediate which is intermediate
between moments is always a period of
time now he talks about an interval okay
so we got all these notions mixed into
this word point which is also which
cannot be defined or or you cannot talk
about it really much unless you bring in
the line yeah you gotta bring in the
line but neither the point or the line
are referring to the geometric figures
known as dot and line they're referring
to distance to displacement to intervals
they're referring to something else that
because that's where they're going to
use them
and as if length and time could be
composed of indivisible x' right they
could be divided into indivisible x' and
yeah that's the notion as you see at the
bottom of the kronum that we have as far
as time is concerned a proposed wantable
time that is a discrete an indivisible
unit of time as part of a hypothesis
that proposes that time is not
continuous and again they're using the
notion today is that continuous is the
opposite of what Aristotle said you know
his notion was that continues is a bunch
of discrete you know lined up so so you
can see what's happening here and this
is where we start remember this is where
we started out with geometry and we
built upon this and that's where
mathematical physics stands upon this
quicksand made by all these Greeks Betsy
I guess Aristotle which again probably
took notions that he inherited from his
teachers passed it down and you could
got it from him and so on down line we
got from Euclid you know so we got it
all the way did today nobody challenged
this it's like nobody challenged any of
the nonsense that these people put down
because they were mixing all these
concepts one with another one okay so
these are the conclusions to which mr.
area arrives and I try to illustrate it
there says no continuous thing is
divisible into things without parts okay
so it's got to have parts otherwise
you're not talking about continuity
infinitely divisible is continuous okay
so continuous means infinitely divisible
that that's his conclusion okay and
everything continues is divisible into
divisible x' that are infinitely
divisible if it's indivisible then you
don't have a continuous whatever line
playing solid whatever but then the next
point says the extremities of things
that are continuous with one another are
one and are in contact so here you have
two lines made of points I guess
but it continues because the line you
know is chopped up into points so so far
we're continues we don't know what each
point does but least so far we have
continuity according to Aristotle but he
says that they must be in contact with
each other okay
to make that whole thing say okay now we
have something that isn't continues okay
and as you can see his corollary there
applies equally to magnitude two time
into motion so again you know what does
any of that with this time have to do
with geometry I have no idea but this is
the problem that we're going to start
out with this is remember this is the
dawn of civilization and this we're
going to in the West we're going to
inherit all this from Aristotle went
through the Arabs right but it ended up
back in the West and these are the
notions were going to build mathematical
physics upon okay so now we have a few
years later like 1200 but a little more
in the 13th century we have mr. st.
Thomas Aquinas an Italian who travelled
a little bit around Europe and he
studied a lot and he was a religious
individual okay and he's going to take
all these notions from Aristotle and
from another phone known as both yes and
boëthius was a 5th 6th century
individual who was a right-hand man of
Theodoric the great one of the mafia
guys of those days they call him Caesars
Kings and whatever I call mafia guys and
Theodoric put him in prison because you
suspected that boethius was plotting
against them to overthrow him so he put
him in prison for about a year then
executed him but before both years was
executed he had a lot of time to think
in prison it happens to a lot of us and
so he thought aloud he thunk and he came
up with ideas of because he was a very
learned guy here and he need like five
languages among them Greek
so he took their Aristotle's work and he
tried to do something with it he tried
to apply it and he'd applied it to
freewill versus determinism trying to
figure out that and also to time and
infinity FS eternity and why was this
important well it was important because
freewill versus determinism had to do a
lot with time okay
and I'll get to that in a second now as
I get into st. Thomas what st. Thomas
did he took the ideas of Aristotle and
both he is who who both dealt with these
subjects right he kind of studies these
two follows seven hundred years after
both yes right and he says you know he
applies them to free will and
determinism he said what does that have
to do with geometry what does it have to
do with the point and with a line I mean
I thought we were talking about points
and lines here right something we end up
with what with free will and determinism
what's got to do a time that's what it's
got to do with and the question was you
know you had this issue about the past
and the future and the question was
whether God knew the future because if
God knew the future and knew everything
that was gonna happen you did not have
free will say so this this is the key
point here now we have a big problem
because I thought I had free will I
could do anything I wanted but it turns
out God already knew what I was going to
do that means the film is already there
I'm just an actor in a film that's been
already made the block universe kind of
idea ring a bell
okay so so this is where the issue comes
in into play here and yeah so Thomas st.
Thomas Aquinas he he applied this
concept he says there are six phases of
free will for new tasks on sensu intense
your D Ben our PTO who sues and fructose
okay so if you want to have free will
you got to go through all these phases
you have it they have the will the
consent
in tension-free judgment use and
enjoyment and again all this has to do
with time he was trying to figure out
whether God knew in advance you know
what you were gonna do and if so do we
have free will
okay so this was the issue and how does
he try to justify this well again he
goes to Aristotle and goes to Euclid he
uses Euclid as well Boethius
and he says okay let's see let's see how
I can figure this out and he does an
immense treaty that he write trick
treaties that he writes about these
subjects good and so he writes this
thing damn and he says the fine this is
one of his conclusions he with respect
to time he says time is not the same
thing as eternity okay he said time and
eternity are two different things these
are these are his conclusions he says
time you can have like you know you can
have a second an hour a day and and the
second is part with an hour and an hour
it's part of a day okay but there's a
before a second in and after second so
it's like the second has end points to
it whereas eternity you know it's like
it extends forever so there's no end
point at either end there's always
something after that because we're still
going to Eternity right and as long as
you walk through eternity you'll never
find an end and so he says he's two are
not the same things okay and then the
issue was whether these things are
chopped up again he comes so he's got to
start with geometry again he's got to
start he brings him back to point and he
does analyze the point and the line
because that's what he's talking about
he's gonna apply the the point to
location and the line to distance to
motion displacement and obviously if you
move well the clock is running right so
you've got time in there as well so you
see how this is how this is developing
this whole thing this eventually is
tying Stein right all these other people
who talk about time and invented time
back into the end of the 19th century
you know Lorenson
Fitzgerald and so on and we'll deal with
that in a little further on but this
deal with time and how geometry and the
point in the line fit into this notion
of time and motion and displacement and
distance and you know this is this is
where we're gonna have a problem because
the the part of geometry the point in
the line what you what they draw on the
board okay that's a physical object and
I've got nothing to do with all these
concepts and you have to remember that
what's happening here is that what these
people are doing is that they're mixing
objects with concepts and we end up you
say so what well we got a problem
because we get things like field the
field becomes a physical object when
field is a concept and you have another
concept called energy and it becomes
something that you know is is a physical
object you transfer energy and you have
mass and mass is a concept you know how
much you weigh kind of thing and this
somehow you begin moving masses around
or the mass has the ability to move a
star around okay so you see where this
is going and it all starts with these
fellows okay
so that's one of the issues for for
Thomas Aquinas that he that he's going
to use this issue of eternity and
whether God knows the future whether
that gives you free will so it was an
important issue for him so he wanted to
resolve that to see if if he can
reconcile God's omniscience with free
will that was one issue but a more
important issue as far as I'm concerned
also you'll see where this thickness is
that and a lot of people don't know this
but Thomas Aquinas he's the guy who
discovered and invented quantum
mechanics he wrote a book on quantum
mechanics people are not even aware of
that okay and here's a little bit of a
summary guy I want you to see it okay
and this is his book his treatise on
quantum particles and he asked these
questions these are the questions he's
going to answer he says whether a
particle is altogether incorporeal
whether a particle is composed of matter
in form whether the particles in it are
in any great number whether the
particles different species were the
different kinds of particles well the
particle is in in place it has a
location has you know occupies the
location a position right whether a
particle can be in several places at
once
and whether several particles can be at
the same time in the same place in other
words known as superposition okay
the other one was decoherence right well
the particle passes through the
intermediate space okay you know the
moves and it doesn't pass through some
point in between and whether the mumma
no particle is instantaneous can a
particle move instantaneously okay and
he wrote about this in the 13th century
but the one I like the most is is is
this other one that that he's got here
wrong one hold it got the wrong one it's
this one here it's here right
I lost it
I think it's this one that wrong one
give me a second here I'll get it now
here it is I just labeled it wrong sorry
about that this is the one that I like
the most and it goes like this says
whether in the in the angel to
understand is to exist oh so he wasn't
talking about partings he was talking
about angels I guess that's what he
called them in those days right but you
can see all that applies to everything
that was done in Roaring Twenties
today we call them particles he called
them angels but the questions are all
the same okay so uh good old Thomas
Aquinas should be given a retroactive
noble maybe you know for discovering
quantum mechanics and that statement
there whether an angel if he understands
that makes him exist that's uh Descartes
I think therefore I am
so those notions were already around you
know for a long time okay so I'm gonna
continue with mr. Aquinas especially the
issues that he raises with respect to
quantum mechanics and I had one more
thing here a couple more things
this was the summary essentially you
know these are foundations of
mathematical physics they have to do
with points and lines and they have to
do with weather with with these issues
by the time is made of points an
instance weather motions made of points
or in locations weather locations are
made of points known as numbers whether
length of time is made of points known
as dots and you know you have the issue
of space having dimensions but no
surface all these have to do these are
the foundations of physics today they
they have all these issues
okay they consider them philosophy but
this is the underlying hypothesis or
assumptions of mathematical physics they
have these same issues today nothing has
changed and all these issues were
discussed discussed by the Greeks and by
people like Aquinas you know that all
these people have dealt with these
issues for a long time now
and so these are not new concepts
they've been around for a long time they
were just dismissed as philosophy and
see if I did yeah yeah I want to show
this this is the one of the issues that
Aquinas tried to explain and that's
whether an angel can go from A to C
without going through B can you jump
over and this is a quantum mechanics
notion today you know where again you
know the angel or the particle I guess
they call them today I can jump from A
to C without going through B can a
particle B at many places at the same
time can a particle can many particles
be at one place at the same time and so
all these issues as you can see they've
been around for a long time all we did
now is give Nobel prizes to people who
we claimed invented them but if things
would have been around and you have to
give credit to the Thomas here because
he did not have the benefit of
accelerators okay he did this all of my
reasoning only by reasoning and so in
that sense you got to give him credit
for that at least right okay so we'll
see you on Wednesday we're gonna
continue with some of this quantum
mechanics invented by mr. Aquinas and
how they relate to the point in the line
and we're gonna see that there's so many
similarities between quantum mechanics
and what mr. Aquinas discovered you know
centuries ago and it all goes back to
the Greeks who started out at the wrong
foot and built this quicksand on which
mathematical physics today lays its
solid foundations we'll see you on what
is it on Wednesday we'll see you that
bye bye